meine mama auch wie betreuen wir die
kinder wie ist das eigentlich wenn es
wärmer wird sind das bessere oder
schlechtere bedingungen für den virus
ich bin taxi und in harmonisch wollte
wissen ob ich meine ausfälle stadtkirche
ich habe eigentlich nur eine frage wann
dürfen wir wieder kontakt mitunter
neckel kindern haben jeden tag neue
entwicklungen jeden tag verschärfte
maßnahmen und jeden tag viele viele
fragen
die wollen wir heute wieder für sie
beantworten herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren zdf spezial wie so entfällt für
heute über die lage im land sprechen wir
gleich mit dem bundesgesundheitsminister
hier in der sendung davor geht unser
blick nach bayern schon heute morgen hat
die bayerische staatsregierung den
katastrophenfall festgestellt wie jetzt
im gesamten land werden auch dort die
schutzmaßnahmen massiv ausgeweitet viele
geschäfte müssen schließen restaurants
dürfen nur noch zeitweise öffnen kinos
jugendhäuser bäder und fitnesscenter
alles muss dicht machen wie diese
entscheidung aufgenommen wird und was
das für die menschen bedeutet zeigt uns
claudia formann üblicherweise ist
münchen an magnet für touristen und
jeder der hierher kommt macht der
marienplatz halt oder schaut auf dem
viktualienmarkt vorbei in den
fußgängerzonen ist überschaubarer
betriebenen läden auch das wird sich
noch verstärken viele geschäfte werden
schließen müssen das hat bayerns
ministerpräsident heute bekannt gegeben
das oberste ziel ist der schutz der
bevölkerung
wir wollen so gut es geht zu gutes
möglich ist unseren beitrag leisten um
diese krise zu bewältigen
der katastrophenfall ermöglicht der
staatsregierung ein zentrales eingreifen
die steuerung von behörden und
hilfsorganisationen in bayern werden
bars kinos schwimmbäder und spielplätze
geschlossen
auch der einzelhandel ist betroffen ab
mittwoch werden geschäfte geschlossen
die nicht zur grundversorgung beitragen
wie dieser buchladen oder diese
souvenirgeschäft hochprozentiges läuft
in zeiten wie diesen besonders gut doch
ab mittwoch wird auch sein laden zu
bleiben
man muss die mitarbeiter eigentlich auch
schützen
und ich würde sagen das muss auch sein
es sind notfälle aber es kommt natürlich
auf die zeit auf an
irgendwo wird dann auch der spielraum
für den lebensmittelhandel hingegen
werden die ladenöffnungszeiten
ausgedehnt apotheken baumärkten
reinigungen bleiben offen speiselokale
müssen für einen großen sitzabstand
sorgen mehr als 30 personen dürfen nicht
bewertet werden und um 15 uhr müssen die
gaststätten schließen
im hotel zur post wird in der küche
weiter gearbeitet auch wenn es abend
geschäft bald völlig wegbrechen wird
jürgen braren macht rouladen krise hin
oder her
gegessen wird immer die leute müssen
essen wir müssen ja irgendwie ne grund
ernährung für die leute darstellen dass
reservierungsbuch ist übersichtlich
viele stornierungen keine neuen
buchungen über kurz oder lang müssen
wohl mitarbeiter entlassen werden
mit zehn milliarden euro wie markus
söder der wirtschaft nun unter die arme
greifen
es wird eine soforthilfe geben eine
soforthilfe für betriebe die jetzt
unmittelbar in not kommen
es handelt sich hierbei um betriebe vor
allem aus der gastrobereich aus dem
tourismusbereich aus dem handel
aber ich sage das ausdrücklich auch für
alle kulturschaffenden deutschland
schottet sich ab am grenzübergang
kiefersfelden etwa die grenze von
österreich nach bayern dürfen nur noch
berufspendler und der güterverkehr
passieren bayern hat als erstes
bundesland den katastrophenfall
festgestellt
am nachmittag wurde die schlange vor
diesem goldhändler in münchen immer
länger und zugeschaltet aus berlin ist
jens spahn der bundesgesundheitsminister
guten abend schönen guten abend herr
sparen erst bayern jetzt sehen die
anderen ländern nach in ganz deutschland
werden viele geschäfte schließen
schwimmbäder kinos spielplätze alles
soll zu machen
befinden wir uns jetzt im notbetrieb
entscheidend ist ja vor allem aus dass
die grundversorgung sichergestellt ist
und mir war immer wichtig in den letzten
tagen auch als viele falschmeldungen in
den sozialen medien unterwegs waren
dass supermärkte das
lebensmittelversorgung apotheken
drogerien tankstellen banken dass die
grundversorgung sichergestellt bleibt
und gleichzeitig wir aufgrund der
dynamik die wir haben also bei der zahl
der neu
infizierten aber übrigens auch mit blick
in unsere nachbarländer dass dort
intensiv wartungskapazitäten knapp
werden dass sie bei dieser dynamik eben
auch maßnahmen weitere ergreifen mussten
zusammen mit den ländern
viele verstehen einfach nicht warum
diese entscheidungen so nach und nach
fallen war nicht letzte woche auch schon
klar dass das virus nicht aufzuhalten
ist und diese maßnahmen eigentlich
zwingend sind sie haben recht das virus
ist da es wird auch bleiben es geht
darum dass wir eben seine verbreitung so
weit es geht verlangsamt das ist eine
sehr dynamische lage
ich verstehe dass einige fragen warum
wusstet ihr dass alles vor vier tagen
noch nicht so also wir wussten dass wir
zu diesen maßnahmen mal kommen müssen
wahrscheinlich wussten aber nicht wie
schnell und das ist wichtig mit einander
zu verstehen weil auch dann nur
vertrauen das weiß ich auch bestehen
bleibt dass das eben nicht linear sich
entwickelt sondern wirklich sehr
dynamisch und wir eben in bestimmten
bereichen sehen dass etwa intensiv und
beratungskapazitäten mehr und schneller
gebraucht werden auch in nachbarländern
als wir das vorher noch vermutet hatten
und wir haben jetzt die chance wenn wir
frühzeitig die verbreitung verlangsamt
dass wir eben bilder wie in anderen
ländern vermeiden
eine ganz kurze nachfrage dazu wenn wir
so nach und nach entscheiden verlieren
wir da nicht ganz wichtige zeit
wir sind noch vergleichsweise früh mit
unseren maßnahmen im vergleich zu
anderen ländern wir können jetzt immer
streiten doch man hätte ein paar tage
früher oder ein paar tage später wichtig
finde ich dass wir jeden tag die lage
bewerten dass wir sehen dass wir noch am
anfang der dynamik in deutschland sind
das wirklich sehr ausdrücklich sagen wir
werden noch viel schwieriger lagen
wahrscheinlich sehen in den nächsten
tagen mit der steigenden zahl wir müssen
ja sehen die infektionen die wir heute
oder morgen sehen auch in der statistik
sehen die sind ja letzte woche
entstanden also auch durch die maßnahmen
die wir jetzt ergreifen werden wir eine
verbesserung bei neuinfektionen und bei
behandlungsbedarf wahrscheinlich erst
zeitverzögert in ein zwei wochen sehen
und das miteinander immer wieder so zu
analysieren das ist im grunde das was
für uns als gesellschaft auch im
miteinander wichtig ist ganz so viel
geht jetzt nicht mehr
ausgangssperren werden jetzt der letzte
schritt oder möglicherweise der nächste
schritt denken sie darüber nach
ich finde jetzt erstmal wichtig dass wir
auch wenn wir haben jetzt ziemlich stark
in das leben der bürger eingegriffen um
es auch mal deutlich zu sagen
kindergärten schulen zu sie haben gerade
die maßnahmen beschrieben in bayern in
anderen bundesländern in nordrhein
westfalen berlin die ja auch schon
geltend was restaurants clubs
fitnessstudios angeht das sind ja
massive eingriffe in den alltag
übrigens auch für die unternehmer die
dahinter natürlich sind und deren
existenz bedroht ist und ich finde wir
sollten jetzt miteinander die nächsten
tage auch schauen wie diese maßnahmen
greifen und da müssen die bürgerinnen
und bürger das will ich auch deutlich
sagen auch mithelfen es bringt wenig
wenn wir diese maßnahmen ergreifen und
gleichzeitig aber alle ansonsten ihr
privates soziales leben noch verstärken
sozusagen als ausweichreaktionen das
funktioniert nur zusammen wenn jetzt
auch jeder mithilft kontakte weiter zu
haben aber eben über telefon und social
media aber nicht direkt entspannt und
trotzdem immer wieder hört man menschen
sagen das ist so eine hysterie ist wir
sollen und keine panik machen
wie kann man denn oder was werden sie
dafür tun dass wirklich alle menschen
diesen ernste lage dann auch verstehen
ich kann alle nur dann auffordern nach
italien zu schauen ich möchte die
situation dass dort 80 85 jährigen die
beatmungsgeräte wieder abgenommen werden
und sie sterben dann damit man 60 65
jährigen helfen kann weil man zu wenig
beatmungsgeräte hat ich möchte eine
situation so eine in deutschland so weit
es geht vermeiden
das sind sehr sehr harte 10 in italien
müssen sich menschen von ihren
angehörigen verabschieden während des
sterbens per telefon weil man sich nicht
mehr sehen kann das sind sehr sehr harte
situation für alle dort auch für die
ärzte und die pflegekräfte und das ist
nicht weit weg und das hat eine dynamik
in wenigen tagen wochen hat sich das in
italien so entwickelt und wir haben alle
gemeinsam jetzt auch die verantwortung
aber auch die möglichkeit zu alles dafür
zu tun dass das eben bei uns in
deutschland gar nicht oder zumindest mal
so wenig als möglich sich auch
entwickelt und ich kann nur jeden der
sagt das ist doch alles nicht so schlimm
einfach nur sagen schauen sie sich an
wie es sich in norditalien entwickelt
hat und wie es sich mittlerweile auch
in einigen unserer nachbarländer
entwickelt die botschaft ist angekommen
die entspannende
bundesgesundheitsminister vielen dank
sehr gerne um das virus zu bremsen ist
wohl die einschneidendste maßnahme die
quarantäne offiziell angeordnet kann man
sich ihr nicht widersetzen
aber auch die freiwillige quarantäne
macht nur dann sinn wenn auch hier die
regeln eingehalten werden wohnung oder
haus nicht verlassen füße vertreten nur
in den räumen einkaufen auf die straße
gehen nicht erlaubt für alle betroffenen
eine absolute extremsituation
allein das ist schon sehr belastend wenn
dann auch noch vorwürfe hass und
stigmatisierung folgen kann einem das
richtig angst machen
stefan hand hier wird heute nicht
gespielt die julius moses kita in
münster seit zwei wochen herrscht
stillstand
mein name ist lisa seewald und ich bin
die einrichtungsleitung der asb julius
moses kita wir mussten vor gut zwei
wochen die einrichtung schließen da eine
unserer kolleginnen positiv auf das
corona virus getestet wurde und unsere
kinder und familien sowie die
mitarbeiter der einrichtung wurden für
14 tage unter quarantäne gestellt wer
das liest bekommt es mit der angst zu
tun infektionsschutz quarantäne
zwangsmaßnahmen aber was heißt das
eigentlich wenn man unter quarantäne
gestellt wird mein name ist franziska
ich bin verheiratet wir haben für kinder
ein junger hund und zwei katzen und wir
alle waren jetzt in quarantäne
auch ihre tochter geht in die betroffene
kita das kam ganz plötzlich und hat uns
sehr überrascht
wir haben uns auch erschrocken das ist
plötzlich auch so nah ist das ist
natürlich mit vier kindern und jungen
hund und zwei katzen eine ganz schöne
herausforderung die wir da plötzlich auf
uns nehmen mussten wer kümmert sich um
den hund wer macht die einkäufe es war
dann schon möglich auch menschen zu
organisieren
aber die freiheit aus aufzugeben und das
in andere hände zu legen war gar nicht
einfach
und dann die überraschende wendung schon
nach zwei tagen wird die quarantäne
aufgehoben aber nur für die eltern
wir hatten trotzdem auch bedenken das
haus zu verlassen weil er schon eine auf
ruhe gibt unter den menschen
es wurde mir vorgeworfen das ist
unverantwortlich sei dass mein mann
arbeiten geht und das war eine ganze
firma auch in gefahr bringt und ich
sollte mir doch gut überlegen ob ich
wirklich auch noch einkaufen gehen würde
wir sind eigentlich nur mit dem hund
raus gegangen damit er sein geschäft
verrichten kann ja und haben uns nicht
getraut uns wirklich unter menschen zu
bewegen und es war neben dieser angst
als auch so das wäre auch nicht schuld
sein wollten dass wir vielleicht doch
jemanden anstecken könnten
die kinder stehen unter quarantäne aber
die eltern dürfen raus das sorgt für
verunsicherung warum diese entscheidung
wir fragen nach beim gesundheitsamt
münster für die haushaltsgemeinschaft
erkrankter kinder oder erzieherinnen
gelten die strengen regelungen der
kategorie eins weil durch die engen
kontakte die ansteckungsgefahr besonders
hoch ist
bei den übrigen kindern und
erzieherinnen oder hausbewohnern gelten
wegen der weniger engen kontakte die
allgemeinen empfehlungen zur hygiene
kontakt reduktion und wachsamkeit ob
symptome auftreten
im klartext laut gesundheitsamt müssen
nur die menschen in quarantäne die einen
direkten kontakt zu einer infizierten
person hatten quarantäne oder gar eine
infektion die vorstellung sorgt bei
vielen für verunsicherung und oft
schlecht sorge in wut um hier wird der
ärger gegen die erzieherin rausgelassen
in den sozialen medien
so etwas sollte bestraft werden wir
müssen definitiv die kosten mittragen
[Musik]
ausfindig machen und ihr die gerechte
strafe geben wie fahrlässig domann sein
kann aber auch kinder loslassen
halleluja manche kommentare habe mich
wirklich schockiert
einfach weil ich nicht nachvollziehen
kann wie man über eine situation und
besonders auch über eine person urteilen
kann ohne die genauen hintergründe zu
kennen unsere kollegin hat absolut
richtig absolute verantwortungsbewusst
gehandelt
sie würde niemals absichtlich das risiko
eingehen jemanden anzustecken und solche
kommentare zu lesen das macht schon
ärgerlich
die suche nach einem sündenbock sie hat
begonnen experten überrascht das nicht
mein name ist auch wie trenne ich bin
hier direkt am institut für
nachhaltigkeitsforschung und meine
spezialität ist risikoforschung vor
allem im bereich der wahrnehmung von
risiken in der bevölkerung angst führt
dann schnell zu schuldzuweisungen wenn
ich nicht den aggressor wirklich
angreifen kann also den virus kann ich
selber nicht angreifen
der ist einfach da und deshalb versuche
ich
ersatz formen zu finden oder auch ersatz
personen oder auch ersatz gegenstände
von den eindruck habe die können meine
wut gegen den virus in irgendeiner form
kanalisieren und dann wird diese
aggression die gegend virus eigentlich
habe auf eine andere person übertragen
die dafür aber gar nix kann mein mann
und ich wir haben gemeinsam überlegt ob
überhaupt dieses interview machen freuen
und das hat den einfachen grund da wenn
ich sie abschätzen können wie die
menschen darauf reagieren ja und für uns
war ganz schnell klar dass das bei uns
zu hause nicht geht weil wir unsere
kinder schützen wollen
vor eventuellen an verhandlungen das
macht uns wirklich sehr betroffen dass
bei uns überhaupt solche gedanken machen
müssen
ich habe keine angst vor dem virus ich
habe angst davor was es aus dem menschen
macht oder machen kann
wir machen die erzieherin keine vorwürfe
so wie wir auch keine vorwürfe machen
wenn er eine erkältung hat oder eine
grippe hat wir hoffen sehr dass die
erzieherin auch in unserer kita bleiben
möchte
die kita in münster bleibt jedenfalls
erst mal bis nach ostern geschlossen
ab heute sind nahezu alle schulen und
kindergärten geschlossen und das bis
nach den osterferien das ist eine lange
zeit viel zeit hatten die einrichtungen
nicht sich auf diese ausnahme situation
vorzubereiten gelernt soll trotzdem
werden jede schule muss sich was
einfallen lassen was sie den
schülerinnen und schülern wie sie den
schülerinnen und schüler ihren lernstoff
vermittelt und so haben auch lehrerinnen
und lehrer nicht einfach frei in manchen
schulen herrscht für sie
anwesenheitspflicht lars ricken über
geschlossene schulen und die große
stille in kindergärten
an allen hamburger schuld ohren heute
morgen das gleiche bild eintritt
verboten für rückkehrer aus den
risikogebieten für alle anderen gilt
eine notbetreuung ist immer
gewährleistet wenn die eltern den
schriftlich bestätigen dass sie in den
ferien in keinem gefährdeten bereich
waren den fast hamburg weiter als andere
bundesländer und vor allem von der
gesundheits vom gesundheitsamt hamburg
das ist noch liegt noch drüber also da
haben wir jetzt auch noch mal die
schweiz und österreich als ganzes so
zusagen bekommen und das
robert-koch-institut glaube ich hat
jetzt erstmal nur die skigebiete bin
1000 schüler sind hier normalerweise von
der grundschule bis zum abitur
heute kam tatsächlich nur ein kind das
der schulsekretärin wir bauen da
tatsächlich auf das
verantwortungsbewusstsein der menschen
dass sie ehrlich sind und dass sie ihre
kinder zu hause lassen es besteht
eigentlich auch kein grund dafür es gibt
ja eine notbetreuung hier und wenn man
in quarantäne ist es man quarantäne so
viel verantwortungsbewusstsein glaube
ich haben unsere eltern die
weiterführenden schulen wie hier die
leibnizschule in wiesbaden organisieren
den unterricht für zu hause
die lernmaterialien konnten die schüler
am vormittag noch abholen
wir haben heute jetzt die möglichkeit
bekommen unsere arbeitsaufträge für die
zeit ab zu holen weil man schon haben
wir blätter bekommen quasi und
arbeitsaufträge und manche bekommen wir
halt digital auch die kitas bieten
deutschlandweit not betreuungen an wie
dieser kindergarten der uniklinik bonn
das krankenhaus möchte sicherstellen
dass das personal im notfall zur
verfügung steht viele bundesländer haben
diese vorgabe auch für die
schulbetreuung gemacht systemrelevante
berufe bevorzugt ich bin
krankenschwester bin alleinerziehend und
ja also ich fall quasi unter diese
relevanten leute die arbeiten müssen und
darum den betreuung bekommen
für die kommenden tage wollen alle
bundesländer e learning angebote für die
schüler erarbeiten home office also für
die ganze familie bei uns im studio
begrüße ich jetzt stefan mross
schulleiter aus mainz schön cool ride
hermuss wir habe es gerade gehört also
ferien sind das nicht es wird gearbeitet
wie haben sie sich in ihrer schule
organisiert naja sind wir mal ehrlich
also als wir am freitag die
schulschließung bekannt gegeben haben
ist schon ein lächeln über das gesicht
der schüler gerutscht das lässt sich ja
nicht vermeiden wenn die aussicht da ist
dass man für viele tage wochen nicht in
der schule sein kann aber es war vorher
schon bekannt gegeben die gerüchte sind
ja schon umgegangen dass wir den
unterricht weiter fortsetzen würden und
das machen wir palandt plattformen und
da sind die schülerinnen und schüler
darauf eingestellt und die kolleginnen
und kollegen auch also ganz konkret per
lernplattformen sie haben heute zum
unterricht aufgerufen aber wie
funktioniert es ja also wir haben für
alle fächer kurse in denen die
kolleginnen kollegen materialien bereit
stellen können aber auch aufgabentypen
zur verfügung haben mit denen die
schülerinnen und schüler lernen können
wo gruppen ergebnisse abgegeben werden
können diskussionen geführt werden und
so weiter und das ist heute morgen los
gegangen also um zehn nach acht waren
von meiner neunten klasse 18 leute
eingeloggt und die anderen acht haben
sich dann auch noch eingefunden
digitalisierung hilft in solchen zeiten
sie machen das so können dass alle
schulen oder wie viele können das also
ich kann von uns sprechen wir haben
glück gehabt dass wir darauf vorbereitet
waren weil wir schon vor vielen jahren
diese land plattform eingeführt haben
und damit die kolleginnen und kollegen
und auch die schülerinnen und schüler
damit bereits umgehen können
ich glaube in schulen in denen er per e
mail kommuniziert wird ist es jetzt
schwieriger aber natürlich auch möglich
diese aufgaben die sie jetzt den
schülern stellen strukturieren ja auch
so ein tag für mehrere wochen das ist ja
wahrscheinlich auch nicht ganz unwichtig
was für ein tipp haben sie dann an die
eltern sollen die sich daneben setzen
sollen die von sich aus mit den schülern
jetzt viel stoff machen viel lernen
praktische ratschlag ich glaube dass wir
das schlimmste was man machen kann denn
so funktioniert hier kein lernen und es
ist einfach sinnvoll dass die
schülerinnen und schüler jetzt
eigenverantwortlich voranschreiten das
werden nicht alle gleich gut machen
ich denke es wichtig dass die eltern
sich wie im normalen schulbetrieb auch
darauf dafür interessieren was die
kinder machen
das ist ja auch sinnvoll wenn die schule
ganz normal am laufen ist aber jetzt ist
es vielleicht nochmal interessanter
zimmer nachzufragen was ist denn heute
passiert und wenn das gemacht ist ist
eigentlich das was wir von unseren
eltern erwarten würden getan
neben dran setzen und die aufgaben lösen
ist sicher keine gute idee wer die
leistungen benotet
es kann auch einer benotung zugeführt
werden selbstverständlich dass auch über
sind die schülerinnen und schüler auch
informiert aber dass da sind natürlich
jetzt die möglichkeiten ein bisschen
geringer aber durchaus ist es auch
möglich mit dieser lernplattform das zu
organisieren
die schülerinnen und schüler merken ja
genau das das sind keine normalen freien
ferien sind sie müssen lernen auf der
anderen seite einen seite auf der
anderen seite merken sie auch was los
ist die sehr beschäftigt die
schülerinnen und schüler dass sie selber
familienvater wie gehen sie damit um
erklären sie viel beruhigen sie ja wir
sind natürlich im gespräch über die
dinge die jetzt alle täglich ablaufen
aber in unserer familie herrscht jetzt
keine panik wir haben allerdings schon
auch überlegt wie das ablaufen wenn
jetzt die kinder über paar wochen zu
hause sind ich bin meistens nicht
zuhause von daher werde ich jetzt nicht
sehr stark in die konflikte die dann
möglicherweise stattfinden könnten
eingebunden sein
aber ich sag mal bei meinen kindern
erwarte ich natürlich auch keiner stelle
von vielen dank dass sie bei uns waren
für diese information wir haben noch was
was sie auch interessieren wird das zdf
unterstützt sie nämlich in ihrer
tätigkeit
schauen sie mal digitaler lernstoff für
kinder und jugendliche auch das zdf
hatte einiges im angebot
in der zdf mediathek finden sie unser
virtuelles klassenzimmer spielerisches
lernen für die ganz kleinen schlauer
sendungen für grundschüler und lernstoff
auch für die mittel- und oberstufe
die inhalte werden ständig erweitert der
lernstoff wird also nicht so schnell
ausgehen
schauen sie gerne mal rein wenn sie
mögen unter zdf.de mit ferien hat das
also alles nichts zu tun wenn jetzt die
schulen schließen das haben auch die
meisten schülerinnen und schüler
spätestens jetzt nach diesem gespräch
schnell verstanden
natürlich merken selbst die kleinsten
dass dies eine absolute
ausnahmesituation ist auch sie machen
sich sorgen sind verunsichert
das gilt auch für die eltern viele haben
jetzt ein echtes problem wie soll die
kinder für so eine lange zeit betreut
werden in vielen fällen arbeiten mutter
und vater die großeltern fallen als
betreuer aus also was tun
eltern haben doch eine aufsichtspflicht
kann man nicht einfach von der arbeit zu
hause bleiben eine frage die wir oft
gestellt bekamen über ihre rechten
rechte und pflichten caracas unsere
sonne da fehlt schon im system sage ich
jetzt mal wir würden jetzt dann alles
mögliche unternehmen und da irgendwo
eine lösung zu finden
aber momentan muss ich sagen sind wir
natürlich etwas allein klassen rumtollen
an frischer luft normalerweise genießt
stefanie weihrauch das mit ihren
töchtern
doch die freude ist getrübt denn die
alleinerziehende ist nicht freiwillig zu
hause die schule ihrer älteren tochter
sina wurde wegen eines corona falls im
kollegium schon vor einer woche
geschlossen so schnell fand stefanie war
auch keine andere betreuung
somit muss ich zu hause bleiben und die
frage was natürlich gegen arbeitgeber
wir dass wir das organisieren und es ist
halt ich muss meinen meinen privaten
urlaub im endeffekt dafür opfern sage
ich jetzt mal seit heute trifft dieses
problem wohl hunderttausende eltern
bundesweit bleiben die meisten schulen
und kitas zu als das am freitag
verkündet wird fragt sich stefanie
weihrauch was das für sie bedeutet denn
sie selbst arbeitet in einer kita die
jetzt geschlossen wird doch für kinder
von systemkritischen personal die
krankenschwestern ärzten und polizisten
muss eine notbetreuung sichergestellt
werden
betreuung die von erzieherinnen wie
stefanie weihrauch geleistet werden soll
wer in den kommenden wochen dann ihre
kinder betreuen kann weiß sie nicht ihre
mutter die sonst oft auf die mädchen
aufpasst fällt aktuell aus weil ich ja
eben meine mama schützen will was heißt
dass es ja ältere personen verstärkt
trifft mit diesem virus und ich möchte
zu schützen und möchte meine kinder
ungern jetzt in die betreuung von meiner
mama geben ja von dem er gestaltet sich
schwierig offiziell stehen stefanie
weihrauch und ihre töchter bislang nicht
unter quarantäne
doch die situation ist unklar denn
allein aus kapazitätsgründen konnte das
zuständige gesundheitsamt bislang noch
nicht alle kontakt ketten der erkrankten
lehrerin ermitteln möglich also dass die
quarantäne erst noch kommt
arbeitsrechtlich hängt davon viel ab
denn ohne quarantäne hat stefanie war
auch kein anrecht auf lohn wenn sie die
kinder zu hause betreut
zwar gibt es den paragrafen 616 im
bürgerlichen gesetzbuch der bei
unverschuldeter vorübergehende
verhinderung eine lohnfortzahlung
vorsieht jedoch so befürchtet
arbeitsrechtlerin gute milena felix
helfen wird dieser paragraph betroffenen
arbeitnehmern nicht unbedingt das
problem am 616 bgb ist dass er auf diese
situation natürlich überhaupt nicht
zugeschnitten ist es ist völlig unklar
ob der in dieser situation greift ob man
tatsächlich einen not vor
zahlungsanspruch danach dann hätte
vorgesehen ist er für wirklich
unvorhergesehene vorfälle bei denen man
eben seine dienstleistung nicht
erbringen kann das auch nur maximal für
fünf tage bislang zur nutzung des
paragrafen müsste man außerdem
nachweisen dass tatsächlich keine andere
betreuungsmöglichkeit besteht kaum
machbar
die arbeitsrechtlerin rät jedem
betroffenen arbeitnehmer dass er mit
seinem arbeitgeber primär ins gespräch
geht und gemeinsam nach einer
konstruktiven lösungssuche
das könnte ein abbau von überstunden
sein oder ein negatives zeitkonto dass
man später wieder aufbaut arbeitszeiten
könnten verschoben werden wenn möglich
in absprache mit dem arbeitgeber des
partners genau das hat richard stegherr
getan auf die schule seiner kinder ist
seit einer woche geschlossen
zunächst hat seine frau überstunden
abgebaut jetzt will auch er sich an der
betreuung beteiligen und hat home office
beantragt obwohl er in der probezeit
darauf eigentlich noch kein anrecht
hätte belegt der arbeitgeber ein steak
er ist dennoch skeptisch
es gibt zwar über die sozialen netze usw
aufgaben für die kinder die aber
schätzungsweise ca 2 stunden umfassen
und die restliche zeit müssen wir
schauen wie wir quasi unsere kinder
betreuen können
das heißt eben auch home office dass ich
nicht in ruhe arbeiten kann und das
könnte eventuell ein problem geben
momentan aber gibt es für viele eltern
in deutschland keine andere lösung
richard stieg er hofft jetzt auf die
politik der schulausfälle dieser art
wünsche ich mir auf jeden fall dass die
gesetzgeber aktiv werden muss weil eine
regelung nur für kräfte die eben
besonders wichtig sind die eben dann
betreuung bekommen für ihre kinder
das kann eben eigentlich hohe aus meiner
sicht nicht ganz sein
heute können kinderpflegerin stefanie
weil rauchen ihre töchter noch zu hause
betreuen
ab mittwoch soll sie stand heute jedoch
wieder in der kita arbeiten für ihre
kinder dann betreut weiß sie noch nicht
zugeschaltet aus frankfurt ist jetzt dr
martin stürmer virologe und
lehrbeauftragte an der uni frankfurt
guten abend schön abend erst über das
virus bremsen die verbreitung eindämmen
darum geht es bei all den maßnahmen wenn
kindergärten und schulen zu machen wie
konsequenten müssen eltern dann zu hause
sein soll man seine kinder noch zu
freunden zu nachbarn zum spielen
schicken
ja es ist eine sehr gute frage steigen
sollte man das nicht weil wir genau das
vermeiden wollen dass die kinder
untereinander das virus möglicherweise
austauschen und entsprechend dann ihre
eltern infizieren also konsequenterweise
müsste man seine kinder mehr oder
weniger alleine betreuen
das betrifft dann auch tatsächlich die
betreuung weil viele eltern hört man
hier aus auch unserem umfeld wollen sich
zusammentun müssen sich auch zusammentun
und gemeinsam auf die kinder aufpassen
aber genau diese durchmischung soll
eigentlich verhindert werden ist doch
richtig oder sonst genau das ist richtig
aber das ist halt dass man kann nicht
beides haben wenn sie auf der einen
seite sagen sie möchten schulen
schließen kindergärten schließen
dann muss irgendwie die betreuung der
kinder gewährleistet sein und wie sie
richtig gesagt haben vielen bleibt gar
nichts anderes übrig als die kinder
vielleicht in gruppen zu betreuen
das ist so optimal zugegebenermaßen aber
das ist die realität wenn es perfekt
läuft dann bleiben die kinder alleine
wenn die infektionen jetzt so schnell
ansteigen wie den letzten tagen wie wird
sich die lage in deutschland am ende der
woche zu stützen
ja also man muss ja ein bisschen nach
italien fielen die letztendlich als
erste den großen ausbruch in europa
gehabt haben und es ist ein bisschen zu
befürchten dass wir tendenziell
italienische verhältnisse bekommen
vielleicht nicht unbedingt was die
sterblichkeit angeht weil da ist die
situation dadurch die altersstruktur und
das enge zusammenleben der eltern mit
den großeltern und den kindern etwas
anders aber so ein bisschen in die
richtung das gehen
die letzte frage da warten eigentlich
alle drauf auf diesen punkt
wann wir wirklich merken dass diese
ganzen einschränkungen was bringen wann
wird es soweit sein
ja wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen dass ab
heute oder morgen diese maßnahmen
konsequent durchgeführt werden
dann könnte sich ja heute noch jemand
infizieren und derjenige müsste dann 14
tage abwarten bis dann spätestens die
infektion stattgefunden hat also in
maximal spätestens zwei wochen rechne
ich damit dass wir anfangen die
wirksamkeit zu sehen
ganz am anfang der sendung hat ein
zuschauer gefragt was verändert sich an
der ausbreitung wenn es jetzt wärmer
wird
das ist eine sehr gute frage wir kennen
das von anderen erkältungs erregern dass
die saisonal auftreten spricht im winter
vermehrt modellrechnungen zeigen dass es
durchaus ein temperatur effekt auf das
corona virus geben kann auch das neue
aber der ist nicht sehr stark ausgeprägt
ist also zu befürchten dass das virus
uns erhalten bleibt im sommer auch wenn
die infektionszahlen abgeschwächt werden
ich danke ihnen sehr für diese
einschätzungen und schöne grüße nach
frankfurt vielen dank
die aktuelle situation in unserem land
ist für so viele menschen eine echte
herausforderung eine belastung
diese krise verändert viel schweißt auch
zusammen und zeigt dass solidarisches
handeln ein echtes miteinander und stark
machen
da gibt es hilfe für menschen die das
haus nicht verlassen dürfen es gibt
viele gute beispiele überall in
deutschland und es gibt mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen von behörden zum
beispiel die bis an ihre persönliche
grenze gehen um immer wieder neue
herausforderungen zu meistern ist wenn
henry kannten es herrscht
ausnahmezustand für die
gesundheitsbehörde der städteregion
aachen das sogenannte abstrich zentrum
hilft mit arztpraxen und krankenhäuser
bei tests von patienten auf das corona
virus zu entlasten alles unter höchsten
sicherheitsmaßnahmen wie sogenannte
schwarz bereich hier finden die
abstriche statt der darf eben nur mit
schutzkleidung betreten werden
das eine ganz kurze prozedur mund auf
und stäbchen hinten in den rachen und
dann stellt schon wieder raus und wir
bekommen 24 bis 36 stunden später die
ergebnisse in unserer gesundheitsamt
geliefert
169 bestätigte fälle meldet die
städteregion aachen heute allein das
abstrich zentrum hat über 1000 tests
durchgeführt
nicht jeder kann einfach kommen und sich
testen lassen an der schleuse draußen
kontrolliert das ordnungsamt denn nur
mit einem vereinbarten termin kommt man
hier rein
den erhält wer mit den mitarbeitern im
call center spricht und von ihnen als
potenziell infiziert eingestuft wird
bei allem stress findet
gesundheitsdezernent simons trotzdem
etwas positives in dieser krise wenn man
was gutes finden kann ist zu erleben wie
die menschen an ra zusammengewachsen
sind in der krise wie hier zusammen
gearbeitet wird wie mitarbeiter über
sich hinauswachsen
wir haben in einer woche zwei call
center und ein abstrich zentrum
hochgezogen sagt mir noch mal jemand
kommunalverwaltung werde nicht flexibel
und spontan das glaube ich jetzt nicht
während sich die einen noch auf corona
testen lassen leben anderer schon in
quarantäne sowie ute eller aus baden
baden die ein videotagebuch gedreht hat
ihr ehemann ist seit dem gemeinsamen
skiurlaub in tirol mit cupid 19
infiziert versorgt werden die ella's von
einer verwandten sie ist aktuell die
einzige die kontakt zur familie hat wo
keine freunde und verwandten helfen
können springen die verdienste ein wie
hier in siegen seit einigen tagen haben
melanie krämer und ihre kollegen viel zu
tun
hier ist eine relativ große bestellung
auch mit dreimal toilettenpapier
funktion denke das ist wichtig für den
kunden nur dass dann alles wirklich
dabei ist melanie krämer holt die online
bestellten produkte bei lokalen
einzelhändlern ab und liefert sie an die
kunden aus seitdem sich die korona
meldungen häufen gehen 50 prozent mehr
bestellungen ein
manche menschen sind mehr verunsicherte
andere halt nicht und bei denen
die fangen wir dann halt die kiste bis
an die tür und dann gehen wir halt
wieder so ist das dann halt im moment ja
die schlepperei wie es manchmal ganz
schön anstrengen dagmar eckert ist 63
jahre alt und diabetikerin gehört also
zur corona risikogruppe ich finde es
einen allgemeinen guten service und
natürlich wenn ich selber auch
vielleicht angeschlagen bin warum ist es
doch schön wenn ich mir die sachen auch
jetzt zu zeiten von corona liefern
lassen kann
ich habe ein paar konzern mit dabei weil
man das ja so im moment ja macht ne
flaute herrscht dagegen an den ständen
dieses wochenmarkt in düsseldorf das
virus ist natürlich das thema
corona virus das land soll stillstehen
freunde von mir wir alten abstand etc pp
möchte euch jetzt nicht mit bus und bahn
fahren was mich wundert ist dass leute
klopapier kaufen kann essen aktions
mittel oder so was halt
die sorge ist recht unterschiedlich
verteilt aber es gibt auch botschaften
bei denen sich alle einig sind ist es
sehr wichtig dass die leute vernünftig
bleiben ja sich nicht umarmen aber
trotzdem nie waren
[Musik]
wenn sich die schutzmaßnahmen jetzt tag
für tag verschärfen dann werden sich
auch die wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen
weiter zuspitzen restaurants brauchen
weniger arbeitskräfte genauso wie hotels
und schwimmbäder und fitnessstudios
tausende menschen bangen um ihre jobs
müssen finanzielle einbußen hinnehmen
oder zumindest für eine gewisse zeit
kurz arbeiten
christoph schneider das hotel kosten
gehört zu den alteingesessenen betrieben
in heinsberg in nrw jedem landkreis der
in den letzten wochen bundesweit am
meisten aufmerksamkeit wegen der
verbreitung des corona virus bekam
hotelchefin terry alhorn luke führt das
haus in vierter generation und steht
jetzt vor der tiefsten krise
wir brauchen die übernachtungsgäste
genauso wie restaurantgästen unser leben
im endeffekt bestreiten zu können
nicht nur mein persönliches sondern auch
das zu meinem team und bin vom wir
sprechen rede ich nicht nur von meinem
hotel und meinem team sondern auch in
den anderen kollegen und kolleginnen die
in der gleichen situation stecken wie
wir in der vergangenen woche hatte das
hotel nur drei übernachtungsgäste
insgesamt die hotelchefin muss von tag
zu tag planen denkt über kurzarbeit nach
wenn betriebe arbeitszeit verringern
müssen und kurzarbeit anzeigen zahlt die
bundesagentur für arbeit
kurzarbeitergeld hauptzweck ist die
weiterbeschäftigung von angestellten
entlassungen sollen vermieden werden von
den 13 mitarbeiter unseren aktuellen
neun mitarbeiter im team die anderen
sind im endeffekt schon in einer art
zwangsurlaub in zwei drei wochen werde
ich meinen mitarbeiterstamm
wahrscheinlich immer noch haben
allerdings werden stunden
auch hier wird man in nächster zeit an
kurzarbeit und stundenkürzungen denken
müssen in dieser ausflugsgaststätte am
berliner wannsee gastronom stefan
kirschner rückt nicht nur tische
auseinander sondern muss auch seinen
betrieb zusammen halten die die lager
sind gefüllt kassen leer mitarbeiter
stehen parat wir haben das team
aufgebaut für den saisonstart wohl auch
darauf gehofft haben und wir brauchen
liquidität zuschüsse wir brauchen ganz
klar kurzfristiges geld um
entscheidungen zu treffen
besonders betroffen vom wirtschaftlichen
stillstand sind auch messebauer wie
hartmut sei sich aus dem
niedersächsischen springe
nach der absage von vielen messen
verzeichnet er rekordverdächtige
einnahmeausfälle
für uns bedeutet das dass wir in den
letzten zwei wochen eben
projekt ausfälle haben im gegenwert von
etwa 1,2 millionen euro nur innerhalb
dieses relativ kurzen zeitraum ist am
vergangenen freitag haben bundestag und
bundesrat im eilverfahren die
neuregelung des kurzarbeitergeldes
beschlossen
unternehmen können dieses geld
beantragen wenn zehn prozent der
beschäftigten im betrieb von
arbeitsausfall betroffen sind statt
zuvor ein drittel arbeitgebern werden
die sozialversicherungsbeiträge die sie
auch bei kurzer bei zahlen müssen in
voller höhe erstattet die kurzarbeit sie
wird auch bei den fluggesellschaften
lufthansa und condor kommen ebenso beim
größten reisekonzern der welt tui
darüber wollen wir noch mal ganz kurz
sprechen mit felix zimmermann aus der
zdf rechts redaktion der scc im studio
schön dass du da bist felix wenn man
arbeitgeber jetzt kurzarbeit macht
machen will muss ich da eigentlich
mitmachen kann der mich dazu zwingen
ja das kommt drauf an und zwar darauf ab
dass vereinbart wurde ob der
arbeitnehmer das vereinbart hat im
arbeitsvertrag im tarifvertrag oder
betriebsvereinbarung wenn nicht dann
kann der arbeitnehmer sagen nein mach
ich nicht aber das könnte angesichts der
aktuellen lage riskant sein das
kurzarbeitergeld ist ja dafür da
betriebs betriebsbedingte kündigungen zu
vermeiden
und wenn man dann sagt nein ich mache
das nicht dann könnte so eine kündigung
natürlich ins haus flattern
allerdings sollte der arbeitnehmer auch
aufpassen ist es jetzt wirklich der die
korona krise unter der das unternehmen
leidet oder wird es vielleicht nur
vorgeschoben
also da muss man genau hingucken corinna
krise ja oder nein lass ich mich darauf
ein auf die kurzarbeit wie lange bekomme
ich das kurzarbeitergeld und wie hoch
ist eigentlich also 12 12 monate sind
möglich und die höhe hängt vom konkreten
verdienst ausfallen ab und ist
unterschiedlich wenn man ein kind hat 67
prozent des verdienstausfalls wenn man
kein kind hat 60 machen am beispiel
einer arbeitnehmerin verdient 2000 euro
netto und wird vom arbeitgeber komplett
nach hause geschickt hätte also 0
und jetzt kriegt sie davon 60 prozent
das wären also 1200 euro für den für den
zeitraum ja und der arbeitgeber da
kriegt das komplette geldes kommt
komplette kurzarbeitergeld ja wie wir
gerade gehört haben
vom staat erstattet das können viele
milliarden werden wenn jetzt immer mehr
betriebe zu machen müssen für eine
gewisse zeit machen sich natürlich viele
menschen sorgen generell um das gehalt
woher bekommen die das war auch eine
wichtige frage von zuschauern immer
wieder woher kommen sie
bekommen sie ihr geld prinzipiell ist es
so wenn ein unternehmen schließen muss
weil die auftragslage nicht stimmt oder
wenn die schließung angeordnet wird dann
ist es das betriebsrisiko des
unternehmens das bedeutet eigentlich
bekommt der arbeitnehmer weiter das geld
nun aber wir gehört haben
die lage ist sehr ernst und wenn es
jetzt so weiter geht dann werden wohl
betriebsbedingte kündigungen kommen
sei denn es ist eine sinnvolle regelung
wird kurzarbeitergeld organisiert ja und
wenn die kommen ist letztlich die
absicherung des arbeitnehmers bei einer
kündigung nur das arbeitslosengeld eine
frage die uns auch immer wieder gestellt
wurde
wenn man in quarantäne muss bekomme ich
dann das geld weiter da sieht die lage
so zu sagen noch am besten aus da wird
kommt man sowohl als arbeitnehmer das
sind vollen lohn für den zeitraum der
quarantäne nicht nur sechs wochen und
auch als selbstständiger bekomme ich
hier dann das erstattet was ich
normalerweise dort verdient hätte
ansonsten sieht die lage gerade für
selbstständige schlecht aus wir haben
keine erstattungsansprüche und da muss
man jetzt auf die politik warten ob da
irgendetwas geschaffen wird von vielen
dank für die spannende innovationen und
vor dem besuch heute hier ein dankeschön
deutschland der alltag wird angehalten
seit heute ist klar auch wir müssen noch
mehr tun um dieses virus zu stoppen
bei all den einschränkungen und großen
einschnitten sollten wir die wichtigen
kleinen maßnahmen aber nicht vergessen
maßnahmen die jeder von uns umsetzen
kann
darum zwei meter abstand zu jedem in der
öffentlichkeit und am arbeitsplatz
bitte denken sie daran auch das kann
helfen
wie halten sie weiterhin auf dem
laufenden ständige updates gibt es auf
der heute de unsere nachrichten
plattform im netz mit vielen
hintergründen und wichtigen
informationen
das war unser zdf spezial hier geht es
jetzt weiter mit dem fernsehfilm der
woche ihnen allen noch einen schönen
abend und danke für ihr interesse
[Musik]
neues vom alten ist einfach friedlich
eingeschlafen friedlich eingeschlafen
ist ganz natürlich und natürlich geht
zum mord die tochter haben sich um geld
gestritten ich habe ihre leiche
einstiche von subkutanen injektion
entdeckt man mögliche tun dass der alte
freitag 20 15 im zdf
[Musik]
mutter 40 tochter 15 er eingeschlafen
hessens suchen